folks in charlotte should be very
excited about it we're going to see
lamelo ball right now jeff he checked in
during the timeout
wearing number two for charlotte b.j
washington from ball
on the g-back star the global bio-risk
advisory council
david i don't have to tell you what that
is the g back star is the gold standard
for safe
facilities carter williams matches up
against graham
bridges to ball out of the corner
rattles in for three
bismack biambo has checked in former
magic player
ball same spot same result
back to back threes by lamelo ball out
of the right corner
played last year in australia getting
all of the loose balls are getting out
and getting easy buckets in transition a
lot of great hustle plays being made
washington gets three back
second quarter from orlando charlotte on
top by six ball another three good again
lamelo ball now with three threes in the
game
orlando giving up 51 points already
and turn it over again good hands by
ball this group on the floor doing the
majority of that
here's paul on the lab for
bridges paul has a great feel for the
game doesn't he
has six here's ball
for three the mellow ball is knocked
down four threes tonight two games
against
tirana he's knocked down four tonight
cole
anthony has it taken away
ball on the lob and reaching way back is
miles bridges
unable to convert the three-point play
but the lead is down to eight
mellow ball
[Applause]
[Applause]
left-handed finish by the youngster
paul has played very well snuck that one
up
underneath buchevich